hey everyone and welcome to the amazing
video on real-time operating system a
real-time operating system or rtos is a
type of operating system that is
designed to control and manage real-time
systems these systems require timely and
predictable responses to inputs and
events making them ideal for
applications such as automation Robotics
and embedded systems and rtos allows for
the simultaneous execution of multiple
tasks while providing precise control
over the timing and scheduling of those
tasks one of the most important features
of an rtos is its ability to handle
interrupts efficiently interrupts are
events that occur outside of the normal
execution of the system and they require
immediate action conclusively and rtos
is a specialized operating system
designed for real-time systems that
require timely and predictable responses
to inputs and events it offers precise
control over the timing and scheduling
of the task handle interrupts
efficiently and allows for the
simultaneous execution of multiple tasks
making it ideal for a variety of
applications from automation to robotics
so if you also ever wondered what makes
a system real time and how does it
differ from regular operating systems
well you're in luck because we are about
to find out but before that do subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to see more such interesting
content in future and if you want to
learn more about these types of Concepts
and Cloud Computing Services then our
Celtic postgraduate program in cloud
computing will be the right choice for
you this postgraduate program in cloud
computing will help you become an expert
in Azure and AWS this in-depth course
lets you master key architectural
principles and develop the skills needed
to become a cloud expert it will help
you become an expert in designing
planning and scaling Cloud
implementations our cloud computing
course helps you master the core skill
sets required to design and deploy
dynamically scalable and reliable
applications on Microsoft Azure and AWS
so do check out the course link
mentioned in the description so let's
get started but before we delve into
real-time operating system let's first
understand what an operating system is
an operating system or Os is a software
that manages computer hardware and
software resources providing services to
computer programs and allowing them to
run efficiently examples of popular
operating systems include Windows Mac OS
and Linux now what sets real-time
operating systems apart from regular
operating systems well the key
distinction lies in the ability to
respond to events in a deterministic and
timely manner in a real-time system
meeting deadlines is of utmost
importance it must be able to complete
tasks within specific time time
constraints known as deadlines real-time
operating systems find applications in
various critical domains such as
Aerospace automative medical devices and
Industrial Automation these systems are
designed to handle time critical tasks
and provide a predictable response
imagine an airbag deployment system in a
car it needs to react instantly in the
event of collision that's where
real-time operating systems shine now
let's discuss two types of real-time
operating system hard real time and soft
real time in a hard real time missing a
deadline can lead to catastrophic
consequences these systems are designed
to guarantee that critical tasks are
completed within their deadlines on the
other hand soft real-time systems have
more relaxed timing constraints they are
missing a deadline may not have severe
consequences but real-time operating
systems achieve their deterministic
behavior through various mechanisms one
key component is Task scheduling tasks
are the building blocks of real-time
systems they represent the individual
units of work that need to be executed
the over scheduler decides the order and
timing of task execution to meet the
deadlines another critical aspect is
interrupt handling interrupts are events
that occur externally or internally and
require immediate attention from the
operating system the real-time OS should
respond to these interrupts promptly and
prioritize them based on their urgency
now real-time operating systems also
employ techniques like priority
inversion avoidance where tasked with
higher priorities are not blocked by
lower priority tasks this ensures that
critical tasks are not delayed or
blocked by less important tasks now
let's talk about real-time operating
system kernels the kernel is the core
component of an operating system that
provides essential services to
applications and manages Hardware
resources real-time kernels are designed
to handle time critical tasks
efficiently they provide features such
as fast context switching minimal
interoplatency and deterministic task
scheduling one popular real-time
operating system is free rtos it's an
open source real-time kernel widely used
in embedded systems free rtos offers a
small footprint portability and a rich
set of features it's a great choice for
resource constrained devices where
efficient task management is crucial now
let's explore some raw world examples of
real-time operating system you'll find
them in avionics system controlling
critical aircrafts functions they are
used in medical devices such as
pacemakers where precise timing is vital
real-time operating systems are also
employed in Traffic Control Systems
ensuring smooth traffic flow and
managing signal timings well before we
wrap up let's highlight some challenges
faced in real time operating system
items deterministic behavior requires
careful consideration of hardware and
software interaction designing and
debugging real-time systems can be
complex due to the stringent timing
requirements additionally ensuring
system security and reliability is
crucial as any failure can have severe
consequences but in conclusion real-time
operating systems play a vital role in
time critical applications ensuring
tasks are completed within strict
deadlines they provide deterministic
Behavior prioritize critical tasks and
respond promptly to events from
automative to medical and Industrial
domains real-time operating systems are
powering the technology that keeps our
world running smoothly well here's a
success story of one of our Learners to
boost your confidence do watch this
video
and I am currently living in Algeria I
wanted to experience what is direct to
live I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech from Sample video that with this
course I had the choice to study while I
country and that is how I got this new
job offer with 60 salary high in Finland
I will be leading the cloud computing
unit of my new company we cannot wait to
start our new life in Finland we are old
that's all for today's video we hope you
found this exploration of real-time
operating systems informative and
engaging if you have any questions or
suggestions for future topics please let
us know in the comment section and don't
forget to like And subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon
for more such interesting videos thank
you and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you